hello my name is Caleb Denby and welcome
back to game review today I wanted to go
over a game from the online nations Cup
that finished a little while back this
was a miniature you don't see too many
of those in modern-day chess and it was
a miniature from the former world
champion this wanteth on Anand I well I
guess you know uh what's the world
champion always the world champion right
he was playing against the Russian yawn
and Nepali sheep one of the leaders in
the candidates tournament to be the next
world champion so could be you know
world champion versus future world
champion here yeah you never know
so in this game vichy actually began
with d for young play tonight at six
and after C for g6 tonight C 3 D 5 we
are in the Grunfeld defense now there's
a ton of different ways the white can
play against the green felt in this game
this shows the move C takes d5 Knight
takes d5 this is more or less than main
one and then from here rather than go
into the main main stuff with E for this
she chooses this move Bishop d2 instead
and Bishop d2 is an interesting line in
the main line of the grin felled efore
gets split and it takes c3 b takes c3
and then this bishop becomes very very
strong on this long diagonal and black
looks to break down this deep on and
this C pawn this kind of structure to
get activity with his bishop so what way
does with Bishop d2 its kind of plays
against that idea by bringing his own
bishop to this diagonal instead so
Bishop g7 and now white replies with E
for in after Knight takes c3 we actually
see Bishop takes c3 instead so now
rather than allow black all this counter
play on this diagonal we see after c5
White's just gonna play d5 as he does in
the game and these bishops kind of
nullify each other black actually did
capture on c3 in the game we see B takes
c3 Queen d6 and now the move Queen d2
from Vichy and not Queen d2 is a nice
move highlighting the fact but now that
this dark squared Bishop is gone black
does have some dark squared weaknesses
to contend with on this Kings side
and if he's not careful he might get
checkmated in 17 moves if he's not
careful in the game yun actually castled
and now this she kind of launches his
attack so I'll let you guys at home try
and find the first move in this
devastating attack for Vishy Anand it's
it's very very combative but it does
highlight the fact that you know Black
has weakened a lot of the central
squares around you know this this Queen
right here and he hasn't really
developed any of these pieces to help
support those squares notice the lack of
this Bishop is felt not only on the
Kings side but in the center as well so
try and find some way to take advantage
of these ideas to just immediately begin
to launch your pawn center forward okay
of course the move that fishy played is
the move f4 immediately challenging this
key 5 square creating threats of playing
e5 himself and creating other threats as
well that we'll see later on in the game
the way that Jana chose to play is with
this movie 6 he is trying to break down
white center at the d5 point and fishie
actually has a very very creative
response to this
he simply develops this Knight and after
a takes d5 he's not interested in
recapturing this pawn rather he comes up
with the very very nice move Bishop to
c4 and Bishop c4 is a pretty killer move
it's saying I don't want to recapture
this with the pawn opening up this file
in front of my king I'd much rather take
it with my Bishop putting some pressure
on your Kings side as well and here I
did a little bit of analysis because
Young's next move is actually the move
that gives him more or less a losing
position and I think the best move here
for black is to actually just play d4
kind of admitting that white is going to
get a little bit of activity along this
diagonal but getting a strong powerful
d4 pawn in return for it the game might
continue C takes d4 C takes d4 white can
castle and black can play a move like
Knights c6 here and from here there's
just a wide variety of
ways that white can play you can bring a
rook over to the center you can even
immediately try pushing a move like f5
to open up files most natural to my eyes
was just to play a simple move like
Bishop back to d3 in this case preparing
this move f5 at your leisure and just
beginning your King side attack in the
game though will see that
Anand actually just gets a much much
better version of some of those moves
that we were looking at there and that
is because Yan plays this move Bishop e6
and this move is really the move that
gives vichy the advantage and the reason
why is you're putting this bishop on a
square where after f5 it's actually
going to be attacked and so all of these
attacking lines that white has normally
after move like d4 are just coming a
single tempo faster and in this case a
single tempo was the difference between
an okay position for black and it's just
a a losing position for black rather
than begin with this move at five Misha
first castles and now Yan does play the
move d4 and now white to move and win
the game white to move and more or less
just outright win go ahead try to find
it okay I'm going to reveal it now of
course the move is this move f5
sacrificing this bishop on c4 in
exchange for the extra tempo that you
get here on f5 this should take c4 is
played in the game now a five hits this
Queen on d6
the Queen moves out of the way and then
after the move f6 checkmate is quite
simply unstoppable now a little bit of
controversy about this game I believe
aeon claimed a mouse slipped the move
Queen d7 instead intending to play the
move Queen to d8 when after f6 he had
some brief ideas of how to kind of save
his position with a move like Knight d7
but unfortunately for him this is also
just immediately getting checkmated
after Queen h6
Knight takes f6 and the nice move Knight
g5 so now slipper know he was getting
mini ensured nonetheless
with this clever maneuver by a white ear
so a very impressive show of opening
preparation by Vishy Anand now such an
impressive showing by Yann neppo who has
actually been struggling in this new era
of online tournaments I think he said in
interviews before that he just finds it
difficult to focus to take these as
seriously as he would with over the
board chess hopefully though you know he
gets back on the horse plays some more
events and finds his footing in the
meanwhile though very impressive game
from Vichy andand I really love what
Vichy is doing with his career these
days you do get the sense that he's
playing chess because he really enjoys
the game and it's showing you know he's
playing some very very beautiful chess
in this stage of his career thank you
very much for joining me on this episode
of game review my name is Caleb Denby
and I will see you next time